bon
[Musique]
dernier jeu proposé par nintendo et
énormément attendu par les fans de la
franchise
nous allons parler aujourd'hui de mario
odyssée disponible sur switch mario 10
et nos comptes l'histoire du célèbre
plombier qui doit faire face à bowser
une nouvelle fois pour le stopper dans
sa nouvelle quête qui cette fois est de
se marier avec la princesse peach de
force pas aux heures recrutera des
wedding planners nommer les blue dogs
pour l'aider dans sa quête
je vous ai résumé très vulgairement la
chose mais mario di c est beaucoup plus
poignant que ça le jeu et ferait beau et
surtout le gameplay avec capi est dingue
ce nouveau mario possède de très grande
qualité comme certains défauts je ne
dirais pas que c'est le meilleur jeu de
l'année mais je m'amuse réellement sur
ce dernier et je suis bientôt à 6 ans
l'une to dinner bref ne nous attardons
pas plus longtemps dans l'introduction
de cette vidéo les théories ont été
compliquée à imaginer et trouver mais
j'espère tout de même qu'elle vous
plaira
voici donc les trois théories que je
vous propose
pour ceux qui ne savent pas qu'ils aient
capi c'est un chapitre forme provenant
du monde des chapeaux et qui
accompagnera mario dans sa quête pour
retrouver pitch mais aussi tiara la
soeur de capi qui fut aussi enlevé par
bowser capi accompagne mario pour
retrouver tiara à la base
retenez bien ceci cependant la
particularité de capi et lorsque mario
le lance sur certains objets ou ennemis
il peut en prendre contrôle pour
utiliser ses pouvoirs ou je ne sais quoi
mais justement ce qui est dérangeant et
que lorsque capi prend possession d'un
ennemi ce dernier porte un chapeau celui
de mario donc alors est ce que quelque
chose ne se cacherait pas là dessous il
faut savoir tout d'abord que lorsque
mario a rencontré capi ce dernier avait
perdu sa casquette détruite par bowser
et cap et s'est donc installé sur la
tête de mario et c'est à ce moment
précis que la situation devient étrange
mario pourrait être possédées par capi
si nous pouvons contrôler des ennemis
pourquoi pas mario le but de capi et de
retrouver tiara cependant il n'avait
aucun moyen d'y parvenir avant aucun
moyen de vaincre les blue dogs ou de
prendre la ligne électrique sans
posséder un corps physique on va dire
réfléchissez-y bien il est vrai que cela
semble tirée par les cheveux capitaine
gentil comme tout en plus mais ça reste
totalement plausible
nous pouvons par exemple prendre
l'exemple d'une lune du désert où
justement nous devons retrouver le
compagnon de deux chapitres forme
inquiet ces derniers nous indiquent que
leurs amis c'est certainement logé dans
le crâne de quelqu'un sait quelque chose
d'assez creepy est effrayant de plus
nous pouvons contrôler les humains sans
chapeau et prendre possession de leur
corps mario n'est pas si différent d'un
humain car on aurait pu justifier le
fait qu'on contrôle que des monstres
entre guillemets mais non les chapeaux
sont réellement la nouveauté que nous
propose le jeu tout le monde porte un
chapeau est justement ce ne serait pas
une indication pour nous prévenir d'un
danger et chapuis fort ne sont pas
capables de posséder des personnes
possédant déjà un chapeau prenez
l'exemple de new donc city tout le monde
porte un chapeau et chaque humain qui
n'en possèdent pas
vous allez pouvoir le posséder les chefs
qui forme pourrait bien vouloir faire
une sorte d' invasion entre guillemets
même si je sais que la théorie est tirée
par les cheveux pour l'argument que capi
ne peut pas posséder plusieurs personnes
à foix genre mario qui rentre dans un
ennemi ça a l'air d'être un petit peu
comme inception
rappelez vous de la fin du jeu capi
possède mario qui ensuite possédera
bowser qui ensuite pourra rentrer dans
la ligne électrique en compagnie de
pitch a vous de me dire ce que vous en
pensez mais c'est quand même quelque
chose d'assez perturbant voilà la chose
qui m'intrigue le plus dans mario
odyssée qui sont ces blu dolls
d'où vient-il pourquoi des lapins qu'est
ce qu'ils vont devenir
je vais essayer de créer le background
de ces personnages qui ne sont
malheureusement pas assez exploité les
blue dogs sont composées de cinq membres
et sont des wedding planners engagé par
bowser pour mener à bien son mariage
nous avons tous peur stewart
rango et harriet sans oublier leur
leader est certainement mère je pense
madame claude avec son cochon
il faut savoir que les blu dolls n'ont
absolument rien contre mario et ne font
que leur métier c'est-à-dire mener à
bien le mariage du client mais
on ne sait absolument rien d'autre sur
eux à part qu'ils vivent sur le côté
obscur de la lune d'ailleurs sur le côté
obscur de la lune justement nous pouvons
remarquer qu'elle est habitée par de
nombreux lapins donc ce serait des
lapins lunaire logiquement ses lapins
lunaire viennent à la base de mario
galaxy enfin ceux de mario galaxy sont
des lumas normalement mais nous sommes
certainement arriver dans mario 10 est à
un stade d'évolution ou les lapins
vivrait donc sur la lune
les blue dogs y vivent aussi et seraient
donc je pense des lapins lunaire
maintenant essayer de réfléchir là
dessus
le métier des blue dogs et wedding
planners créer et organiser des mariages
est normalement synonyme de bonheur le
mariage est à la base l'union entre deux
personnes qui s'aiment et qui veulent
être heureux ce qui prouve bien qu à la
base de noeuds ce ne sont pas vraiment
de vilaines personnes
les blue doses seraient les descendants
des lapins lunaire qui ont évolué avec
le temps et ce qui m'intrigue le plus et
c'est pour ça que je parlais de bonheur
où est donc passée harmonie elle est
totalement absente de mario odyssée et
on s'attendait à la voir sur la lune
et pourtant néanmoins vous savez que si
j'en parle ce n'est pas pour rien car un
easter egg lui est présent et nous
montre qu harmonie et bien là disponible
en version 8 bits harmonie est présente
sur le côté obscur de la lune comme par
hasard sur la terre des lapins lunaire
et surtout des blue dogs
elle n'est nulle part ailleurs qu est ce
qu on pourrait alors supposer la
présence de cette forme 8 bits nous
prouve qu harmonie et là quelque part et
surveille cet endroit si les blondes aux
sondés la part lunaire cela expliquerait
tout harmonie serait comme leur maman
adoptive
comme pour les lumas à la base j'en suis
sûr et convaincu malheureusement la mer
des bouleaux dose est madame ben rhodes
qui elle par contre possède un réel
mauvais fond je pense
elle est bizarrement similaire à bowser
et lui ressemble beaucoup
plutôt bien habillés nous pourrions
penser que madame blood est avare et
souhaite posséder énormément de lune
pour elle même c'est ce qui expliquerait
son mauvais fond de base après tout on
voulait lui voler ses lunes la première
fois que nous l'avons affronté ces
personnages sont malheureusement très
peu exploités et je ne pense pas que ce
sera la dernière fois que nous
entendrons parler d'eux surtout madame
claude qui je suis certain pourrait être
un sérieux bosse dans un futur mario
retenez bien ce que je vous dis car je
suis sûr que nous les reverrons il le
mérite
ok je vous parlais d'un nouveau mario où
nous pourrions potentiellement revoir
les bruins mais au final se pourrait-il
que ce mario soit le dernier
mario traverse le monde avec l'aide de
capi et ramène le bien dans chaque pays
jusqu'à même la lune ou mario contreras
le mariage forcé de bowser avec la
princesse peach amenons donc les
arguments premièrement pitch a mis un
vent je dirais même un mistral à bowser
et mario sur la nuit bowser ans les
fiches depuis des multitudes de jeu
mario et se maria odyssey nous
prouverait bien quelque chose c'est que
bowser est amoureux de pitch
ce dernier n'a jamais montré les réelles
raisons de vouloir se marier à la
princesse la conclusion serait donc que
c'est pour son bonheur personnel mais
pitch a bien fait comprendre que c'était
non et pour mario aussi justement deux
interprétations nous sont donc possibles
pour mario soit pitch n'est
définitivement pas amoureuse de mario et
du coup cela serait une raison que ce
mario soit le dernier soit que justement
le mariage entre les deux protagonistes
seraient la réelle fin de mario et que
pour continuer l'aventuré pitch ne peut
se marier avec les jeux sont donc bel et
bien animé par l'amour entre guillemets
car mario m la princesse peach mais
bauer aussi et les deux se sont faire
rejeter donc fin du game
de plus le monde est revenu à sa forme
initiale voire même encore meilleur puis
aucune menace n'est présente dans le
monde nous pouvons prendre l'exemple de
pauline qui est l'équivalente de pitch
qui est devenu carrément maire de new
donc city elle ne craint plus rien elle
est même une
2 les seules apparitions de donkey kong
sont des références en 8 bits donc rien
à craindre
ensuite comme on le disait auparavant
les blue dogs ne sont pas de réels
ennemis puisqu'il exécute seulement leur
métier à la base la fin du jeu est
vraiment très explicite aux reste coincé
sur la lune et a bien compris que jamais
il ne pourrait gagner le coeur de la
princesse peach qui maintenant toute
sécurité et se permet même de voyager à
travers le monde sans aucun souci est
dans même mario dans sa quête
d'enlèvement de la princesse peach et
est donc due à un sévère langue d'amour
de la part de bauer qui au fin fond de
lui et mais la princesse peach
cela remet d'ailleurs pas mal de choses
en cause notamment concernant au buzzer
junior mais ça ce sera dans une
prochaine vidéo
si je vois que mes théories sur mario
vous ont plu mario odyssey est vraiment
un grand jeu et mérite son succès j'ai
passé énormément d'heures et je suis
réellement motivés à faire le 100 %
le jeu possède de nombreuses qualités
mais aussi quelques défauts et
franchement qu'est-ce que je passe un
bon moment dessus j'espère que ma vidéo
vous aura plu
merci à ceux qui laisseront un pouce
bleus et qui partageront la vidéo
n'hésitez pas à me suivre sur twitter
pour les plus acharnés d'entre vous
c'est et argo rock et que le liner soit
avec nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]